chelsey asks 600 people at her school
their favorite color and graph the
results some colors are not on Chelsea's
graph how many people chose colors other
than those on Chelsea's graph
so here's Chelsea's graph she made a bar
graph and she listed some favorite
colors blue green red yellow pink and
graphed people who had those favorite
colors but some of these 600 people like
me had a different favorite color my
favorite color orange isn't on the graph
so we're asked how many people like me
were not graphed how many people picked
a color besides blue green yet red
yellow and pink so the way we can figure
this out is if we look at the graph and
figure out how many of the 600 people
are on the graph then we can take that
away from the total 600 people to find
out how many are not on the graph so
we'll start by looking at the graph
first one blue this bar lines up to 90
so 90 people picked blue plus next one
green lines up to 135 a hundred and
thirty five people picked green moving
over to red this bar lines up to
seventy-five 75 more picked red yellow
and pink the bars are the same heights
that means the same amount of people
picked yellow and red and we can move
over and see that that was a hundred and
twenty so one hundred and twenty picked
yellow and another hundred and twenty
picked red so if we combine all of these
numbers combined all the people that are
on the graph that will help us to figure
out how many are not on the graph so
let's start let's start with the ones
zero ones plus five ones as five ones
plus five more ones is ten well zero is
still ten plus zero is still 10 so we
have 10 ones plus let's look at our tens
nine tens plus three tens is 12 tens 12
10s plus seven tens is 1910s 1910s plus
two is
twenty-one tens and two more tens 21 10s
plus two more tens as 23 tens so we have
23 tens or 230 that's zero because we're
talking about tens plus we can now do
our hundreds only few of these had
hundreds we had one hundred plus another
100 is 2 hundreds plus another 100 is
300 so 3 hundreds we have 2 zeros now
we're talking about hundreds three
hundreds and if we add all these 10 plus
230 230 is 240 and 240 plus 300 well
let's see that will still be 40 but 200
plus another 300 is 500 so 540 people
are on the graph but we're asked how
many are not on the graph so up here we
see there are 600 total people were
asked 600 total people and we want to
take away the 540 who were on the graph
and that will tell us how many were not
on the graph if we take these people
away everybody who's left is like me
whose favorite color is not on the graph
so let's do that if we started with 600
and we're subtracting 540 let's the
first subtract the 500 600 minus 500 is
100 but we still need to subtract the
4100 is like 10 tens minus 40 which is 4
tens
10 tens minus 4 tens is 6 tens or 60 so
there were 60 people who chose colors
other than those on Chelsea's graph